un pantalon lycée pour qu'elles
arriveront enfin plutôt un pantalon 80
centimes les températures fraîches sont
arrivés et aux vestiaires de l'antenne
élan courtoise du secours populaire
français les bénévoles voient les
bénéficiaires venir garnir un petit peu
leur garde-robe ça c'est certain que de
toute façon on va certainement être
amené à voir de plus en plus de
personnes pour pour se vêtir pour
ne serait-ce que déjà à l'alimentaire on
se rend compte aussi que il ya quand
même beaucoup plus de personnes donc et
on peut de toute façon étant donné que
c'est ouvert à tout le monde où on
souhaiterait qu'il y ait beaucoup plus
de personnes qui ne sont pas forcément
bénéficiaires mais qui pourraient
bénéficier de prix très intéressants
parmi les inquiétudes l'augmentation des
coûts de la vie au 1er octobre 2021 le
prix du gaz a connu une hausse record de
12 6% depuis le 1er janvier 2020 le
tarif réglementé a augmenté de 44% on
est en train de refaire les dossiers on
est en train de remettre à jour les
situations des personnes et donc on se
rend compte que il ya beaucoup d'impayés
de loyers où il voit d'effectuer les
factures arrivent en ce moment de base
et les d'expliciter donc c'est
maintenant qu'ils vont découvrir que
vont pas avoir les moyens de payer
zohra et mère de six enfants son mari
est au smic elle vient régulièrement
distribution et elle subit de plein
fouet ces diverses augmentations en 1
800 euros les pour logement il reste
presque rien du tout pour tout le monde
c'est la vie vraiment les france
les gasoils référence des voix tu es
vraiment il ya des gens comme en moins
et art il arriva pas vivre la crise de
l'accueil vide a déjà augmenté le nombre
de bénéficiaires de cette antenne les
équipes ont vu arriver dix pour cent
deux personnes supplémentaires
on va on avait eu des familles et des
hôtels sociaux mais aussi mes os
maintenant on en a aussi beaucoup plus
qu'ils viennent aussi des immeubles
sociaux achetés type hlm
donc c'est un peu plus il ya eu une
augmentation quand même cette année avec
les problèmes de qu'ovide mais les
situations pour l'instant son nom pas
trop bouger on pense que ça va être
maintenant qu'on va découvrir les
problèmes de paiement de factures et de
l'accompagnement les 25 bénévoles de
l'antenne et l'entretoise du secours
populaire français soutiennent près de
50 familles bénéficiaires de
distribution sont organisées chaque
semaine